He may have Aliens and T2 under his belt,
but James Cameron has never even attempted
a third franchise movie. Is his impossibly
ambitious vision for Pandora just a pipe dream?
The sequel to 2009's smash hit
Avatar is back at long last,
but fans of James Cameron's record-breaking
franchise have much more to look forward to
even after The Way of Water. Avatar
3 is already pretty much locked in,
and James Cameron has many plans
in place for more Na'vi thrills.
This is why Avatar: The Way of Water doesn't
matter quite as much as you might expect from
a massive end-of-the-year blockbuster
by a filmmaker of Cameron's pedigree.
With a third movie in the works, the immediate
future of the series is already pretty clear,
regardless of how The Way of
Water pans out. Because of this,
the Avatar movie you should really be
paying attention to is the third one.
Virtually everything about the Avatar franchise
will be riding on the third installment, which
won't enjoy the bump in curiosity from fans who
have waited over a decade to return to Pandora.
Early Twitter buzz around Avatar: The
Way of Water has been largely positive,
and why wouldn't it be? Piranha
II: The Spawning notwithstanding,
James Cameron's history as a genre
sequel writer-director is peerless.
"Hasta la vista, baby."
Though even Cameron himself admits that The
Way of Water is a terrible business case,
one that'll need to become one
of the most successful movies
in history just to break even,
it's hard to bet against his CV.
Avatar 3, however, is where things will
get tricky. Cameron is a great filmmaker,
but he's also kinda sporadic. In fact, The Way of
Water is his 21st directing credit in 44 years,
which includes individual TV episodes,
documentaries and short films. While he's
been a nigh-invariable success story
on the director's seat, Cameron is an
unproven helmsman when it comes to steering
a franchise beyond that first sequel. Sure,
he produced Terminator: Dark Fate, but
he has never fully committed to a film
franchise after a sequel — and certainly
not on the scale that Avatar demands.
In other words, Cameron's plan is to venture
far beyond familiar waters. Nevertheless,
the director has laid out plans for multiple
big-budget sequels that are all set in the
same universe, something that's entirely
uncharted territory in his body of work. And
we simply won't know whether he's capable
of doing this until Avatar 3 is released.
Let's be honest: James Cameron could have retired
to a tropical island after pretty much any of his
umpteen smash hit movies. The fact that he has
constantly pushed on, embraced new technology,
and focused on making even more impressive films
is testament to his drive to surpass himself.
Since making a sci-fi sequel is his bread and
butter, The Way of Water is just one dazzling step
in his Avatar masterplan — but this idea can't
truly unfold until Avatar 3 spreads its wings.
As a filmmaker, Cameron certainly has the chops to
deliver multiple epic sci-fi works, and he's had
plenty of time to draft the stories he wants to
tell in this world. But are there enough enticing
stories to tell on Pandora? Or has Cameron become
so enamored by his stylish world that he fails
to see there's not enough substance for his
multi-movie story arc? Only Avatar 3 will tell.
Considering Cameron's tenacity, especially
when it comes to the Avatar movies,
it's clear that he views them as his
biggest, boldest filmmaking move yet.
He has chosen to commit himself to building
a mega-franchise from scratch. What greater
legacy can there be than building an entire,
beloved universe with your own two hands?
None of the major sci-fi franchises
on which Cameron has worked have
peaked past their first two movies. This
creates mighty expectations for Avatar 3,
which is the first "Avatar" movie that forces
Cameron beyond the "successful movie and its
sequel" structure, and into the franchise
territory he seems so keen to explore.
Possibly the best point of comparison
to what Cameron seems to be trying to
do is fellow sci-fi franchise chef George Lucas.
"Hello there."
If Cameron manages to expand his universe the
way Lucas crafted the original Star Wars trilogy,
he might very well turn Avatar into a
multimedia powerhouse. If this happens,
expect to see Pandora-centric movies and TV
shows long after Cameron is gone. However,
if the filmmaker gets lost in the
style-over-substance mode of Lucas'
prequel trilogy, his expensive experiment may
turn into a massive, embarrassing failure.
It's pretty impressive, really. After all, it's
not every day that we see an established superstar
filmmaker swinging for the fences the way Cameron
does with the Avatar movies, especially at this
relatively late stage of his career. When it
comes to Cameron's own reputation as a filmmaker,
Avatar 3 could well be his best chance at
a home run — or an easy way to strike out.
And then there's the money. James Cameron
has said that he is fully prepared to wrap
Pandora up after Avatar 3 if the movies don't
turn in a pretty profit. This financial aspect
further increases the third Avatar movie's
importance in the grand scheme of things. In
a worst case scenario, Avatar 3 will not only
be responsible for its own box office — it's
also Pandora's last line of defense if
Way of the Water's numbers disappoint.
There's a good chance that
will happen, too. Per Variety,
The Way of Water's breakeven point is somewhere
in the vicinity of $2 billion. For comparison,
2022's other major long-gestating sequel,
the highly successful Top Gun: Maverick,
has made $1.48 billion so far. Should
The Way of Water peak at such numbers,
and assuming that Avatar 3 also comes with
a $2 billion profit margin, the movie would
need to make over $2.5 billion to break even and
cover The Way of Water's slack. To achieve this,
Avatar 3 would have to become the third
highest-grossing movie in history.
This hypothetical scenario might seem like a
big ask, but it's not unattainable — at least,
if your name is James Cameron. The movie that
Avatar 3 would need to surpass for that number
three spot is none other than Titanic, which
currently sits at $2.2 billion. Of course,
topping the overall list is the original Avatar,
which has raked in a cool $2.92 billion over the
years, with the September 2022 release alone
boasting a $30-million premiere weekend.
So, if anyone can make these absurd numbers work,
it's James Cameron. Still, it's likely that
even he'll be sweating for quite a while,
seeing as Avatar was the embodiment of "slow
and steady," making a relatively meager $77
million during its opening weekend and building
from there. As such, even if they're successful,
The Way of Water and Avatar 3 may take a long time
to make their billions. Will the studio grow tired
of this high-stakes gambling with achingly slow
returns? Will Avatar 3 need to make an immediate,
colossal box office impact to reassure everyone
involved? This may be yet another reason to keep
an eye on what might turn out to be the
most important movie of Cameron's career.